madeleine la mort est alec castonguay
michel davet de bonsoir or après
l'ontario hier le québec aujourd'hui on
a mis les chiffres sur la table gros
déficit en ontario hier annoncé 33
milliards 12 milliards au québec
alec castonguay avant d'écouter une
minute je veux faire un premier tour de
table
le ministre dit on peut se permettre
d'attendre un bon set à réplication de
rembourser en cinq ans parce que sinon
ça tirait trop lesaffre est trop mal on
veut pour jouer dans le film de philippe
couillard qui avait rapidement voulu
retrouver l'équilibré budgétaire en
utilisant certains diront l'austérité
d'autres la rigueur mais les résultats
étaient les mêmes les québécois n'ont
pas apprécié les services publics en ont
souffert donc on veut se donner la marge
de manoeuvre essentiellement politique
parce qu'en réalité quand on regarde les
chiffres de bonnes chances qu'on
atteigne l'équilibré budgétaire avant
les sept ans prévus notamment parce
qu'on sous-estimé généralement
l'utilisation du fonds des générations
on est toujours en train de mixer des
dépenses alors que des actifs on va
recevoir l'argent du fédéral en matière
de transferts en santé pour les
garderies aussi quand avoir créé son
réseau national on va être compensées
bref je serais pas étonné qu'on y arrive
en cinq ans mais pour quoi faire peur
aux gens dire aux québécois la pandémie
paul filippi rapidement vers tonnelle
équilibre et pas de pression politique
pour le faire en cinq ans même les
libéraux maintenant dix ans devraient le
faire en cette aube huit ans alors le
gouvernement se donne toute la marge de
manoeuvre politique
on va voir le deuxième tableau sur les
nouvelles dépenses alors évidemment on
dans les missions essentielles de l'état
santé éducation pour la relance aussi
deux des secteurs qui ne vont pas bien
culture la culture lundi certaines pme
le tourisme non mais de l'argent schild
avait l'impression générale d'un bon bah
écoutez le retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire non seulement c'est
politiquement la chose à faire mais
objectivement je ne vois pas qui est si
grande urgence de revenir au déficit
zéro en termes de pib le déficit du
québec
et la dance québec réduire et relative
bien relativement modeste c'est bien
pire dans bien des endroits ya alors je
pense pas que ce soit hérétiques
d'aucune façon et comme dit haley
cueilli fort possible que qu'on n'y
arrive plus rapidement maintenant
au total c'est quand même l'opposition
deux extrêmes budget conservateur et je
pense que c'est assez juste dans la
mesure où bon je comprends qu'on peut
pas réinventer la roue à tous les jours
mais les lily recettes afin que monsieur
girard adopte pour la relance économique
sont montrés très classique les
infrastructures on connaît ça depuis 15
ans alors je pense c'est un budget qui
est relativement conservateur et
contrairement par exemple à ce qui avait
évidemment l'an dernier on n'était pas
dans la même situation mais là il ya
beaucoup de clientèle vulnérable qui
vont probablement trouvé que monsieur
gérard a pas été très généreux je pense
par exemple au logement social services
de garde et des centres d'hébergement
pour femmes battues
dans les circonstances il m'apparaît que
monsieur
un coup participants qu'avoir un déficit
de 12 milliards ce gérard aurait pu en
mettre un peu plus en amont à ce test
qui nous parlait tout à l'heure pour du
regroupement des réseaux de maisons pour
femmes violentées des refuges nous
disait elle elle reçoit les maisons vont
recevoir 4 millions de plus par année
pour les sept prochaines années
elle a dit c'est insuffisant nettement
la même région se passera quoi y'a plus
de 100 maisons c'est quoi 4000 $ par
année
c'est très peu madeleine ce que le débat
qu'il ne partira pas et qui va même
s'installer encore plus fermement c'est
les jeudis l'ontario hier annonce un
gros déficit le québec aujourd'hui c'est
les demandes auprès de monsieur trudeau
pour un transfert massif d'argent pour
la santé pour rééquilibrer le déficit
structurel la coop prouver qu'on voit
justement parce qu'il y en a un déficit
rupture est elle qui est inscrit dans ce
budget là 7 milliard et demi de dollars
environ donc ça donne du poids à
l'argument de québec qui lie à des
dépenses qui vont être récurrente
donc là aujourd'hui le gouvernement
fédéral est arrivé par exemple avec
l'argent qui va être envoyée aux
provinces pour la santé pour la
vaccination pour les infrastructures des
municipalités mais en disant c'est un
chacun on en fera pas comme ça tous les
ans et on comprend que le gouvernement
voulait faire ce chèque là avant la fin
de l'année financière pour finalement
avoir ce déficit la inscrits cette année
espérons leur pour le gouvernement
fédéral que les difficiles à l'avenir
vont pouvoir diminuer
donc le gouvernement fédéral hall va
avoir le souci de diminuer son déficit
en même temps que les provinces mondy
rôle à nous on a des dépenses qui ont
augmenté avec la pandémie on l'a vu on a
embauché par exemple des préposés
supplémentaires dans les ch et celle des
donc cette bataille là elle n'est
vraiment pas terminé et je trouve que le
budget du québec ont montré à quel point
finalement elle ne fait que commencer
ah oui ça m'est latin pour pas finir
bien rapidement là-dessus alec et michel
avec justin trudeau s'est déjà engagé à
bonifier les transports en matière de
santé mais il le dit on va attendre la
la pandémie on va attendre d'y voir un
peu plus au québec personne s'attend à
recevoir six milliards de dollars de
plus par année en transferts en santé
comme on le demande
on sait que c'est un jeu de la
négociation mais on s'attend que justin
trudeau en face quand même un peu plus
il a lui même dit qu'il en ferait un peu
plus et que ce soit 1 2 3 milliards de
dollars par année de plus au québec
ça va dépendre la négociation mais c'est
clair qu'on soit en avoir un petit peu
plus
michel la démonstration des besoins puis
du déséquilibre je pense a été fait
depuis longtemps à tous les budgets
c'est encore la même chose cette année
il ya un gros document qui nous explique
tout seul avec des tableaux et des
projections mais au plan du discours
le déficit du québec par rapport à
l'ontario par exemple et plus encore par
rapport à celui que mme adam freeland va
voir annoncé le 19 avril apparaît
relativement modeste alors monsieur
trudeau on va avoir beau jeu de dire
écoutez là je comprends que les
provinces ont des problèmes mais
regardez nous le déficit avec lequel on
est aux prises même si on sait tous que
le gouvernement fédéral est capable de
résorber un déficit beaucoup plus
rapidement que les provinces
au plan des apparences disons monsieur
trouvé tout à fait va pouvoir directeur
on n'est pas dans une situation que le
gros du programme des dons étaient payés
pour les entreprises et pour les indus
par le fédéral alors à court terme le
déficit doit être monstrueux témoin oui
puis le gouvernement fédéral à une
statistique il ressort le plus souvent
possible c'est que sur chaque dollar qui
a été dépensé pour lutter contre la
pandémie à 81 cents qui viennent
d'ottawa donc ça vous allez l'entendre
encore souvent en faisant les provinces
peuvent bien quémander ou demander mais
ottawa a déjà deux niveaux bon taxe
carbone c'est intéressant parce que ça
paraît à rien de les gens du web cour
suprême d'abord si la cour suprême avait
dit ce n'est pas constitutionnel un coup
de tonnerre pour le premier ministre
justin trudeau
c'est son arme pour combattre les
changements climatiques de mettre un
prix sur la consommation de carbone
l'imposé ce prix-là aux provinces qui ne
veulent pas qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres
systèmes comme le québec
je vous montre tweet de monsieur trudeau
qui s'est réjoui de l'addition de la
cour suprême qui a qui a dit non c'est
tout à fait vous avez le droit de faire
ça alors là il est heureux le changement
climatique sont réels etc
et c'est une mesure confirmée par la
cour je vous fais entendre maintenant
monsieur o toole
ça va être une ligne de démarcation
importante lors de la prochaine campagne
qu'elle soit en juin ou en septembre peu
importe on écoute monsieur autour et la
tarification du carbone n'existe pas aux
états unis il y à une compétition pour
les opportunités pour les
investissements pour les emplois entre
le canada et les états unis
c'est injuste c'est c'est inapproprié
on doit cibler sur une relance
économique pour le canada
la pandémie devait aussi avoir un plan
sérieux et claire sur l'environnement
parce que on doit réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre donc madame dame
aurait là dessus c'est clair le chef
conservateur ne changera pas d'idée il
ne vaut pas adopté la taxe carbone d'ici
les prochaines élections et la ligne de
démarcation sera là il va dire manger un
plan sans taxes comme la dernière fois
les libéraux vont dire nous on a un plan
avec taxes qu'on va leur demander vous
nous jusqu'à combien j'allais aller avec
votre taxe que soit efficace oui mais le
plan fantax des reines au tour louis il
dit qu'il va en avoir un mais on ne l'a
pas encore en ville dit qu'il va être
prêt avant les élections donc c'est très
très difficile pour le moment de juger
de son plan ce qu'on sait de son plan
jusqu'à maintenant c'est qu'il va
déchirer la taxe sur le carbone et si le
gouvernement fédéral avait perdu en
cours aujourd'hui
sarr est beaucoup beaucoup aidé r1 au
tour lors la bataille elle va devenir
exclusivement politique
il y aura plus la bataille devant les
tribunaux mais cette bataille là
effectivement il va se poursuivre aux
prochaines élections il va y avoir une
ligne de démarcation
mais quand et reno tous disait bon il y
à une concurrence là déloyale envers les
entreprises canadiennes parce qu aux
etats unis
il n'y a pas cette taxe sur le carbone
l'argument concurrentielle entre le
canada et les états unis vont
probablement s'effriter à la langue avec
joe biden aux états unis qui veut lutter
contre les changements climatiques
aujourd'hui il y avait l'american
petroleum institute un des grands
lobbies qui était à anti taxe carbone a
endossé aujourd'hui l'idée d'un prix sur
le carbone dont vous voyez il ya la
dynamique qui chante joue aussi entre le
canada et des états unis
et l'argument des reines auto va être
plus difficile à faire quand il est
question de conclure à la question oui
je le disais au québec il y à un système
des changes de bourse avec la californie
dont le fédéral ne pas imposer une taxe
carbone mais le québec faisait partie de
ce combat des provinces pour invalider
cette taxe la néanmoins expliqué moi
ouais parce qu'on voulait ce que les
provinces garde toute la marge de
manoeuvre possible pour être capable
même de décider du mécanisme pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques et la
town vient d'obtenir la permission d'en
faire un mécanisme si les provinces n'en
font pas suffisamment parce que le
québec n'a pas de la taxe fédérale sur
le carbone la colombie-britannique non
plus toutes les provinces maritimes non
plus pourquoi parce qu'ils ont tous
développé un système jugé suffisamment
efficace pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques les provinces
conservatrices actuellement dirigé par
des gouvernements conservateurs comme
l'ontario l'alberta la saskatchewan
même le manitoba finalement assez ranger
mais ont décidé qu'elle allait le battre
ce qu'on combatte devant les tribunaux
c'est ce que par rapport à un champ de
compétence le québec allait le défendre
mais en réalité on sur le principe l'on
était plutôt d'accord qu'il faut mettre
un prix sur le carbone
alors on sait aujourd'hui un peu dit
désolé du côté de québec là on va pas
perdre de nuit de sommeil avec david
qu'est ce que ce jugement le change dans
le jeu politique à venir là on finira
mais d'abord je pense que monsieur otto
ils vont être obligés de dire assez
c'est ma valise et dont le jugement le
salaire que les changements climatiques
c'est un phénomène réel là ce que son
parti est 9e partenaire et ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué pour monsieur
o'toole parce que de façon générale la
population canadienne je pense appuie le
principe là où ça va devenir un peu plus
compliqué pour monsieur trudeau s'est
peut-être pas tant à court terme qu'à
l'avenir ce que tout le monde tous les
experts disent que la taxe sur le
carbone oui c'est une nécessité mal est
beaucoup trop basse et qu'éventuellement
il va falloir l'augmenter beaucoup et là
il ya des provinces même celles qui
comme le québec ont des systèmes
alternatif il va falloir qu'ils
s'ajustent et là de dire que si on passe
je sais pas moi de 10 à 200 dollars la
tonne ça commence à faire une taxation
pas mal plus lourd b et d opposition qui
se manifeste pas actuellement pourrait
le faire à l'avenir
oui c'était une des questions du débat
alec souvenez-vous débat des chefs
fédéral la dernière fois parce que
monsieur trudeau d'où ils nous ont fait
ça mais la question puis les
conservateurs lui rappelle à chaque fois
oui mais pour être efficace level le
l'expert ottawa avait dit ça prend une
taxe beaucoup plus élevé ce que les
libéraux ne sont pas prêts actuellement
à faire pour des raisons évidentes
politique rapporte l'avait j'ai
rapidement en conclusion madeleine des
marins on va entendre la vérificatrice
générale qui dit que le canada deux mots
j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça va paraître
une évidence pour plusieurs mais n'était
pas prêt comme plusieurs autres pays
affronter la crise on est cool
lagence ne sais pas si la majorité des
voyageurs ont bien respecté les mesures
de quarantaine
or on ne sait pas si les individus ont
bien respecté les exigences de la
quarantaine et alors c'est impossible de
déterminer si cela compte contribuer à
la propagation du virus
les gens qui revenaient au canada
madeleine la vérificatrice dire on a
perdu leur trace
oui on n'a pas vérifié en fait pour la
plupart d'entre eux ne vérifiait pas
s'il respectait la quarantaine ça ça
peut peut-être vraiment enraciner l'idée
que le gouvernement fédéral a été mou
sur la toute la question de la gestion à
la frontière
on peut se demander par contre est-ce
qu'ils vont payer le prix puisqu'il
avait déjà cette réputation là les
canadiens sont plutôt préoccupés par
est-ce que je vais être vaccinés et
quand ça c'est une chose là toute la
question de la gestion à la frontière
mais ce que la vérificatrice générale
dit aussi c'est que le canada était pas
prêt son agence de santé publique par
exemple était
réduite à devoir entrer à la mitaine des
données qui provenaient des provinces et
ça c'est quand même assez surprenant
alors que vingt et un ans après la crise
du strass on soit encore à se dire que
la coordination fédérale provinciale
fonctionnent à ce niveau là donc c'est
sûr que chaque fois qu'on parle de santé
publique de d'essayer d'être prévoyants
c'est très difficile de demander des
budgets c'est très difficile de de faire
concurrence aux demandes très très très
pressante dans le si dans les systèmes
de santé mais là cette fois ci ça
démontre à quel point ça peut avoir des
conséquences quand on néglige cette
affaire celle david la prévention c'est
pas quelque chose de très populaires
autour d'une table quand il n'y a pas de
crise web alors j'espère qu'on va
prendre tirer les leçons de la crise
actuelle mais je veux surtout pas
défendre le gouvernement trudeau mais le
livre d'alec
nous demandent que le canada était loin
d'être le seul à pau est prêt et avoir
été pris de court je vous rappelle qu'au
québec par exemple il y avait un plan le
quittait qui dormait depuis je pas 10
ans et qu'on n'a jamais mis à jour et
ottawa c'est la même chose il ya eu tout
un rapport qui avait été fait après
l'épisode du strass et on l'enterrait et
il est évident que les coupures qui ont
été pratiqués dans la santé publique
aussi bien ottawa qu'à québec
certainement ont certainement pb moi
j'ai moins rentables la prévention mais
là je pense qu'on a eu de son antre on
verra madeleine avec michel merci
beaucoup
à très bientôt avoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit